j'aimerais moi savoir une journée de
confinement de chacun d'entre vous parce
que franchement c'est réglé les
téléspectateurs vous regarde il disait
ce que les stars vivent comme nous le
confinement par exemple une journée
d'elie semoun et dit c'est quoi ta
journée de confinement moi je me lève
tôt ce que je dors mal
ouais keller leurs taux c'est moins bon
après je vais dans mon jardin je vais
pisser sur mon compost
regardez les abeilles après je regarde
mon téléphone
après j'essaye de me faire à manger je
suis complètement nul pour pour manger
après souvent j'appelle franck dubosc
ont plein de vidéos ensemble donc on
essaye de trouver des bonnes idées
après moi je vous ça va je vais je vais
faire des courses je m'emmerde fois en
fait la journée marquant je suis sur rfm
tous les matins en direct de chez noir
déjà de chez toi avec elodie et albert
et puis ensuite je fais des vidéos tous
les jours j'essaie de faire une vidéo
sera un doublage n'importe quoi indéfini
ou autre chose essayez de cas chaque
jour une vidéo
ça m'occupe beaucoup à ses généraux des
retraites je sais ce que tu fais tous
les jours déjà tu donnes mi-court à ton
fils et l'a fait une panique
qu'est ce qu'on rigole alors c'est quoi
ta journée pensez quoi alors moi je me
réveille tard parce que je dors très
rare qu'on est en période de ramadan
longtemps rare et très tard et je me
réveille très tard vers 12h 13h après je
fais les devants avec mon fils on fait
une petite vidéo avec mon fils ont tous
qui compostent tu fais le tu fais le tu
fais le tu étais tu étais en fourrière
oui j'étais en retour c'est parce que
j'ai pour projet une nouvelle émission
le tour de france c'est super ouais
c'est avec toi en fait tu fais le tour
pendant le ftto en fait voilà qui
explique on casse le jeune lisez le
moment exactement du jeune et on a droit
de manger puis roger boire etc
donc voilà et c'est à 21h15 21h12 en ce
moment donc c'est 2,5 à 4 h du matin
lundi donc voilà après je regardais
syrie en ce moment je regarde michael
jordan de six étages
je te dis donc tu ne ressemble comme
deux gouttes d'eau au musée 2 c'est quoi
la basket made you pertes côté tu vas
faire des nike air boudeur et demi sans
rigoler ce serait alors n'attendez
chantal les ménages ont perdu chez
madoff qui est tombé dans la journée toi
moi et écoute moi je suis comme vous des
acheteurs je me couche très tard
donc je me lève à setar ensuite
j'appelle je fais le tour des copains ça
va alors se dit rien parce que personne
n'a rien de neuf là le seul mec car un
truc à dire quand tu dis quoi de neuf
c'est salomon donc c'est le mec qui t'a
pas du tout envie de poser l'éternelle
professeur d'allemand secteur 8 a pas
envie de lui dire quoi de neuf ans du
tout alors si les autres ils ont rien à
te répondre
c'est rigolo après je fais de la radio
parce que c'est sur rmc tous les ans 14
à 16
mais après je sors je danse jardin je
t'écris philippe non j'écris pas une
ligne mais tu sais pourquoi parce que
j'ai pas envie qu'il reste un truc de
cette période
ouais voilà je comprends c'est quoi ta
journée chantal toi alors moi je me lève
à 7 tours je crée tout parce que je me
couche tard mais je m'endors beaucoup de
venger d'un canapé devant la télévision
le soir parce que j'ai un canapé très
confortable et ça et donc je commence
mes limites au financement mais je me
couche tard et je me réveille très tôt
et j'ai redécouvert le sommeil parce que
je dormais plus vraiment relève
prévaloir paris et j'ai des insomnies
je me couche très tard mais là du coup
orange confite manger retrouver un
rythme et je vous laisse tout on va
faire un peu de course avec michel qui
fait la cuisine j'ai une petite sieste
et voilà l a journée pas savais que je
regarde quand je tiens une vidéo comme
ça je doive me prend 2,3 mais sinon ça
se passe assez relativement vous demain